- Y is equal to 3x, X is equal to 3y.
"Consider the system of equations above.
"How many solutions
does this system have?"
Well when I think about
solutions and systems
I always imagine each of
the equations in our system
is kind of describing a line.
And if the two lines
intersect you're going
to have one solution.
And if they don't intersect,
you're going to have no solutions.
And if they end up being the same line,
so if they end up being the same line
you have an infinite number of solutions.
So let's see, and so who
can immediately rule out,
cause these are linear,
these are linear equations.
Two solutions.
The only way you're
gonna have two solutions
is if one of these lines at
least one of them curves.
So if one of them did something like this,
then you could have two solutions
right there and right there.
But these are both linear equations,
so we could rule out having two solutions.
But let's just think about these up here.
Well what I like to do is I like
to solve them both explicitly for Y.
That's at least how I
like to visualize lines.
This first one up here is already written
explicitly in terms of Y.
This second one over here, let's
divide both sides by three.
And we get Y is equal to x over three.
So this first one is Y is equal to 3x.
The second one is Y is
equal to x over three
or we could say 1/3, 1/3x.
And so these lines, they
don't have the same slope.
They don't have the same slope.
So they're not going to be parallel
and they're not going to be the same line.
So these are going to intersect.
These are going to have one solution,
exactly one solution.
And if you wanted to visualize
this on the coordinate axis
I'll do it really fast.
If that's our Y axis this is our X axis.
X, Y.
This first line right over here,
this is gonna have a slope of three.
So it's gonna be a pretty steep line.
It's gonna look something like this.
And then the second line right over here
is going to have a slope of 1/3.
So it's going to look something like this.
These two clearly intersect.
And actually now that I look it
one way to realize that you're gonna have
at least one solution and you'll see it.
I mean you even see it where they're
intersecting right over here.
The solution is when X and
Y both are equal to zero.
But since you wanna rule out that hey,
maybe it has a infinitely
many solutions is look.
Just think about what
these lines represent.
This first one, very steep
line right over here.
The second one, a much less deep line.
But they're different lines
so they're not the same line.
And they don't have the same slope,
so they're not going to be parallel.
So they're going to intersect
in exactly one point.